[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
RAJ AJRAWAT: Hey, everyone.
My name is Raj Ajrawat, and
I'm a Product Specialist
for the Android platform
here at Google Play.
Today I'm going to
begin our session
by talking about the
Android Go opportunity
and walking through some
details about the product
since we last spoke about it.
I'm then going to invite
my colleague Steve
to come up on stage and walk
you through some of the data
that we're seeing support
all the details as to why
we built Go,
including reasons why
you should keep your app small.
After that, we'll have
Amrit come up on stage
to walk through all
the requirements
that you should pay
attention to when
it comes to optimizing
your app and your game
for these devices.
And finally, I'm going to
have James come up on stage,
and he's going to walk you
through all the details
that we've been doing
on the Play Store
to make sure that
we're delivering
a really awesome store
experience for users
on these devices.
So to start things
off, Android Go
was an ecosystem-wide
effort to make sure
that we delivered a premium
hardware and software
experience for users
on entry-level devices.
Now, in all of the user
research that we did globally,
we found that users had
very specific pain points
on these types of devices.
Those items included processor
speed and quality, storage
capacity, and battery life.
No matter where we
went in the world--
in developed markets,
in developing markets--
users consistently
kept coming up
with those issues on
these types of devices.
So we challenged ourselves,
along with our OEM partners,
to deliver a much more
integrated and better
experience at this
device capability.
It's important to remember
that Android Go is not
a fork of Android.
What we did was we
actually introduced a
build time flag into
the platform that
ensures that all devices that
are 1 gigabyte or less of RAM
going forward are going to
be Go configuration devices.
We worked with all of our
Google teams internally--
from Search to the Assistant
to YouTube and Maps--
to make sure that we
delivered a first-class Google
experience as well to users
who are on these devices.
We also made sure to
introduce pre-load limits.
We definitely don't
want to have users
unboxing super slow phones
the second they buy them.
Let's dive a little bit more
into storage, performance,
and security.
Now, again, referencing
that user research
that we were talking
about earlier,
we noticed that
over 2/3 of users
on devices with 8
gigabytes of flash or less
really only had about
a gigabyte of storage
when it came down to it.
You can't really do much
with a gig of space.
It's 2018.
I want to take pictures.
I want to download apps.
I want to play games.
What we realized was we
needed to do a better
job of actually making
sure that users had
more storage out of the gate.
And what we were able to
accomplish with software
improvements was that users
now have 2X more storage
right off the bat.
That's an additional
1,000 photos
that they can take
on their phone.
Now, it would be
disingenuous of me
to come up here and ask all
of you to optimize your apps
and your games for these
devices if we didn't, ourselves,
actually do the same thing.
So we got together with
all the different product
teams for some of the major
apps that you know and love--
like Search, the
Assistant, Gmail, YouTube--
and made sure that we delivered
a really good experience
from Google on these
particular devices.
Some of our product
teams decided
to remove some features.
Others decided to
add specific features
for these types of devices.
It really just depended
on the use case
for those particular teams.
One of our most popular
apps is actually Files Go.
And in that
scenario, we realized
that we needed to
deliver a better
job for users in terms of
managing space on their phones.
We've been really
excited to see some
of the ratings
and the excitement
that users have with
these particular apps.
Now, security is at
the heart of everything
that we do at Android.
And one of the things that
we launched as part of this
was Google Play Protect.
With the rise of peer-to-peer
sharing and offline
usage of apps, we
wanted to make sure
that users felt very comfortable
with the apps and the games
that they were downloading
onto their phone.
Think of Play Protect
as a badge of trust
that essentially extends
the Play brand to let a user
know that the app or
the game that they're
putting on their phone
can be trusted to be
used on that particular phone.
My colleague James will go
through more details about what
that actually looks
like on a user
experience for these devices.
Now, I'm really
proud of all the work
that we've accomplished
so far over the past year,
but let's take a second
to dive a little bit more
into the opportunity
around why it matters
for you to optimize
your specific experience
for these types of devices.
This chart right here shows
2017 shipments, globally,
for Android devices, broken down
by the RAM on those devices.
As you'll see on
the top-right there,
about 25% of global shipments
every year are devices that
have 1 gigabyte of less a RAM--
sorry, 1 gigabyte
of RAM or less.
That represents about 300
million devices in the market
currently.
Now, we expect the number
to actually increase
throughout the year,
but it just gives you
a general sense for
how many devices
you should expect will actually
have this configuration going
forward.
We've seen a ton of
interest in the market
from all of our OEM partners.
In fact, back at Mobile
World Congress in March,
we had about six
OEMs launch devices.
I'm happy to report now we
have over 80 OEM partners
committed to delivering
devices, with hundreds
more in the pipeline
by the end of the year.
We really cannot thank our
partners enough for all
the work that they've done
to partner with us to deliver
a really awesome hardware
experience for entry-level
devices.
I definitely encourage you
to go out and buy a device,
just so you can feel and see
just how premium the experience
is at such a decent price point.
Now, I want to dive a little
bit more into the Indian market
specifically.
India represents
the largest market
for these types of devices.
We expect about 30
to 35 million devices
by the end of this
year that'll have
the Go configuration on them.
The marketing that
you're seeing right here
is what Micromax is
actually using in-market
to show users just how
premium the experience is.
And the good thing to call out
is that with carrier subsidies,
many of these devices
are actually under $40 US
in these markets.
So very, very good price point,
and still a premium quality
hardware.
Of course, India does represent
the largest opportunity
for these devices, but I can't
stress this point enough--
the US is the second-largest
market for these devices today.
Every time I tell that
to people, everyone
looks at me with blank
stares, because it
doesn't make any sense.
Well, the numbers
prove out that the US
is the second-largest market
for entry-level devices today.
This isn't just a developing
market problem or an emerging
market problem.
This is a developed Western
market, first-world market
problem as well.
Users around the world
at these price points
and at these device
configurations
want to have a
premium experience,
and Go delivers that.
I'd like to now invite my
colleague Steve to come up
on stage to walk you
through some of the data
that we're seeing on the Play
side around all the information
that we see that supports the
reasons why you should invest
in the opportunity as well.
STEVE SUPPE: Hi.
Thanks, Raj.
[APPLAUSE]
Hi, everyone.
My name's Steve.
I'm a Product Manager on
the Google Play Console.
So Raj just introduced
you to Android Go
and talked a little
bit about all the work
that we've been doing to
shrink the storage and memory
footprint of our Google
Apps in preparation for it.
I want to talk to
you a little bit
about the importance
of doing your bit
and the rewards you'll get to
your business and your user
relationships by focusing
on shrinking your app size
and thinking small.
Now, if you haven't gotten
enough data analysis
over the last few days,
hold onto your hats,
because I'm going to show
you a bunch of graphs.
So as devices have gotten
more and more advanced,
developers like you
are making increasing
use of their capabilities,
which is great.
It means you're packing in
more features than ever before.
You're making better
user experiences,
providing more value to users.
But it can come
at a serious cost.
This chart here
that I'm showing--
and you may have
seen it earlier--
shows the average app
size served on Google Play
over the last 10 years.
And you can see very clearly
that app sizes continue
to increase.
In fact, it's grown 250% over
the last five years alone.
And it's still growing.
All that increase in size
may be materially impacting
your user acquisition strategy.
App size has a very real
effect on conversion rates
and the successful
download of your app.
This chart shows the correlation
between app size and user
conversion rates.
Specifically, when I'm
talking about conversions,
I'm talking about users who
come to the Play Store and tap
Install.
That's the conversion
we're talking about here.
Clearly, the heavier your
app-- you can see app size is
the x-axis--
the less likely a user will
be to install your app,
even when we account for
things like Store listing
optimizations.
Size has a very clear
negative impact on
whether or not a user
will want to install
your app on their device.
In fact, the data shows that
for every 6 megabytes that
increases on an app size, we
see a decrease in the user
conversion rate of roughly 1%.
That trend applies to all
apps under 100 megabytes,
and it also applies globally.
That's a material
loss and conversion
that could be recovered if
you focused on app size,
but that's not all.
We can also compare
country by country.
Now, if we compare the
percentage increase
in conversions by reducing
app size by 10 megabytes,
we first of all see--
by the global average--
that worldwide,
users see more benefit.
They tend to install more.
But this can vary dramatically
country by country as well.
Shrinking your app
by 10 megabytes
in a country like
India or Brazil
has a larger impact on
your store conversion rates
than countries like
Germany, the USA, or Japan.
But if you look across
all emerging markets,
the removal of 10
megabytes from an app size
roughly correlates with an
increase in conversion rate
by about 2.5%.
That's pretty big.
But let's drill down
a little bit further.
Often when we talk
about businesses,
we talk about conversion rates.
But we have a different
lens that you might not
have seen before,
because we're also
the ones that serve the app.
So what happens after
a user taps Install?
Well, they still have to
download the app, right?
So we can also measure
what percentage of apps--
by size-- actually fully
make it to the device--
have a 100% transfer rate
and are ready for install.
And that's what this
graph shows here.
So you can see that
as app size increases,
the success of a download
drops precipitously.
Now, this could be for
a variety of reasons
that aren't all shown here.
So for example, it might be
for environmental conditions.
Perhaps in certain
parts of the world,
network quality isn't as high
as we would like it to be.
It's not as reliable as
we would like it to be.
It might also be for
our user actions.
Perhaps the user gets tired of
waiting around for a large app
to download, or maybe once
they're on the download screen,
they see just how large the app
is and they decide to cancel.
The blue line here shows apps--
excuse me, devices--
that have less than
or equal to 1
gigabyte of RAM, which
is the same device profile
as the Android Go devices
we're talking about.
And you can see that the
impact is even more dramatic
for those sorts of devices.
But whatever the
individual reason,
the action you can
take today is clear--
keep your apps small.
In many parts of the world,
users pay attention to app size
when deciding what to download.
This chart shows the
median download size,
country by country, for devices
with less than or equal to 1
gigabyte of RAM.
So in countries with cheap
data or cheap storage
or strong network
reliability, we
see that users have
a natural tendency
to prefer larger apps, which
you can see in the blue.
But in many markets,
particularly
across Africa and Asia,
we see a clear trend
towards smaller apps.
But just to reiterate
Raj's point,
this isn't just an
emerging market problem.
If we look at the median
download size again,
we can see that
the US is roughly
right in the middle
of our global minimum
and our global maximum.
So this implies that roughly
50% of users in the US
and countries like
it also are more
likely to prefer smaller apps.
The US is the second-largest
market for Android Go devices
globally, and I
think these numbers
help to support that statement.
So you might be
saying to yourself,
what's the point of this
part of the presentation?
Is Google really trying to
tell me to remove features
from my app and try and make
my app small by doing that?
Not exactly.
What I'm trying to
do is paint for you
a larger picture of the
decisions and the factors
that you should weigh
when considering
what to do in your app next.
Some of your
decisions might cause
you to lose out on
quality installs
and prevent users from
installing your app.
I'm now going to pass it
to my colleague Amrit, who
will dive more into the
details of how to optimize
your app for Android Go.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
AMRIT SANJEEV: Thanks, Steve.
I'm Amrit Sanjeev.
I'm a Developer Advocate
at Google based in India.
And in this session,
I want to talk
about how you can
optimize your apps to make
them Android Go-ready.
What we have learned
working with our partners
is that when they actually
optimize their apps for Android
Go, it just did not
benefit only the users who
used Android Go devices.
It did help everyone who
was using those apps.
It worked with people who
were in emerged markets,
as well as using
high-end devices.
As you'll hopefully
see, tuning these apps
with these requirements
will enable all your users
and will bring a lot
of benefits for you.
Let's walk through some of the
technical requirements here.
Firstly, you need to set your
target SDK to 26 or above.
This will not only ensure
that you deliver the latest
Android experience to
users, it will also
allow you to comply with
the Play policy change that
requires you to set
the target SDK to n
minus 1 API level, where n
is the latest Android API.
If you're targeting a
version lower right now,
you need to ensure that you
test your apps thoroughly
to make sure that there are
no breakages or functionality
changes because of
this API change.
There are some behavior
changes in API 26,
and you need to
account for that.
Limitations like background
processing, location updates,
notification changes
are some of the examples
of reasons why you might
want to test more thoroughly.
The second requirement
is reduce the APK size.
For apps, we require you
to make it less than 40 MB.
And for games, that's
extended to 65 MB.
That's excluding the
secondary downloads.
When I say 40 MB,
that's the upper limit
that I'm talking about here.
You need to make it
as small as possible.
Here are some of the things
that you could do in order
to reduce your APK size.
Firstly, remove all unnecessary
code and unnecessary libraries
that you have added
into your build,
and ensure that the
libraries that you're adding
are mobile-optimized
and not server-side ones
The drawers in your
resource folder,
they need to be
optimized for both size
as well as for format.
If you're looking for
backward compatibility
and you're adding
support for modules,
ensure that you're adding
only the modules that
are required by the application
and not all of them.
In case your app has audio
resource files like .wav files,
try converting
them to MP3 or AAC,
which are much smaller formats,
thereby reducing the APK size.
But it's not really about
changing these things.
You also need to measure them.
Right?
So if using a
traditional APK format,
you can use the Android APK
Analyzer that shipped along
with Android Studio to
check the sizes of the APK
and also compare it
against the previous one
as you make changes
to see how well you're
making increments in this one.
If you're using the
new app bundle format,
then you might want
to use the bundle tool
and check the size
of the [INAUDIBLE]..
We all know that entry level
devices are RAM constraints.
So you need to check all
your key user features
to ensure that they run
properly without any issues
on a [INAUDIBLE] RAM device.
ANR, janky frames,
out-of-memory exceptions
are things that you
got to watch out for.
So test your apps thoroughly
before you release them
for these problems, and
fix them proactively
before you send it
out in the market.
Once you've actually put
it out there in the market,
you need to observe and
reactively fix issues
as they come.
Android-wide tools, which James
will actually talk about later
on, Firebase, Crashlytics,
and Firebase Performance
Monitoring tool are
some of the SDKs
is that you could use in
order to do this reactive part
really, really well.
Let's take a look at the
requirement for RAM usage.
Start up memory in your apps
should be less than 50 MB.
And for games, that's
extended to 150 MB.
I want to be clear that when
I'm talking about RAM usage,
I'm talking about the
Proportional Set Size
here, or PSS in short.
PSS is basically the sum
of the private memory
your app is using plus the
proportion of the shared
memory with other processors.
Test all your key user
journeys and optimize them
for memory usage.
And make the memory
footprint as low as possible.
A common way to
find this PSS number
is to use the meminfo
command that you
will run from the ADB shell.
Or you could use a
debug memory class
and programmatically
calculate this.
Let's move on to app's
startup time here.
The requirement here is
that apps should start
in less than five seconds.
What I mean startup time in
five seconds, what I mean is,
be fully interactive in
less than five seconds.
We all know that
quick starts are
key to avoid early
uninstalls and abandonment.
A quick startup time is key
in building a perception
that your app loads fast
and is fast for the user.
As a general rule,
you need to ensure
that your app is perceived
to be fast on these devices.
In order to measure
the app startup time,
you could use the Firebase
Performance Monitoring
SDK, which actually calculates
it automatically and shows it
on the Firebase console for you.
We're extremely proud of
the work our partners have
done in order to reduce
size and improve performance
for their users.
We can't thank them
enough for partnering
with us on this initiative
and in providing
a fast-performing and rich
experience for the users.
I'm going to now show you
a video that our team has
put together, highlighting
the experience Flipkart
team had while they
were optimizing
their app for Android Go.
Let's take a look.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[END PLAYBACK]
We are so proud of
the work Flipkart
and all our partners
have done in order
to optimize their
apps for Android Go.
Now, I'm going to hand over
the stage to my colleague
James, who is going to talk
to you about the Play updates.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
JAMES BENDER: Thank you.
Hey, everyone.
I'm James, and I'm a Product
Manager on Google Play.
I work on initiatives like
Android Go, the emerging
markets, and end
user optimizations.
And I'm really excited
to share all the work
that the entire
Play team has put
in over the past couple of years
to deliver a quality Android
experience to our users.
Let's dive into the work
we're doing in the store.
I'm going to chat a
little bit about end user
experience and then
optimizations and improvements
we made under the hood.
And then I'll tell you guys
about some of the tools
that we've developed for
you to make it easier
to build on Android Go.
A key point that I
want to make today
is that there is no Go
version of the Play Store.
It's just the Play
Store optimized for Go.
It's the same Play
Store on every device.
We did this deliberately because
we think that the optimizations
that we can make,
the customer should
be able to take advantage
of those optimizations
on any device that they
may be on, whether it
be a Go device or a Pixel.
We aren't limiting the
catalog on Android Go,
so users get access
to any title that you
choose to distribute to them,
whether your distribution
settings be limited by
location or by device type.
So we kind of need
to set the example.
You've heard today over and
over that small matters.
We went out over the
past year and have
chopped the Play Store in
half from a size perspective.
And we're now just at or below
10 megabytes on all devices
globally.
It's an accomplishment
I'm super proud of.
Users in emerging markets
have made it ultra clear to us
that mobile data
is their currency.
So we ran a couple
of tests and we
showed how expensive any
app download is on a card
and on search results.
And as you could imagine,
users opt for smaller apps,
even if a rating may be lower.
So in a couple of
places, we actually
replaced where we previously had
an app rating with an app size.
We found that showing the APK
size increases install rates
and more importantly,
user engagement over time.
Remember what
Steve said earlier.
APK size does have an
effect on install conversion
and successful install rate.
And with the rise of offline
and peer-to-peer sharing,
Play wanted to ensure that
users could still trust the apps
and games that they
got from us, no matter
where those apps came from.
That's why we
introduced Play Protect.
You can think of it
as a badge of security
that users will know and trust.
So what this does is it gives
users on any device type
confidence that they have a safe
and secure app experience when
they're in interacting
with these apps
in the context of Play.
How did we do it?
We wanted to make
sure that an app can
be trusted on a user's device.
So we started to attach a very
small bit of security metadata
to every app and
game that we publish.
Then, what we can do is if a
user acquires an app offline
or via peer-to-peer,
we can use Play Protect
to read that security
metadata and determine
an app's authenticity
and verify its source.
You, as a developer,
get the added benefit
of being able to service those
apps because we will bring them
into the user's Play library.
And we'll be able to update
those apps in the future.
It's a major pain point that
we know you've relayed to us
and we're excited to
address moving forward.
APK size, the downstream
metrics that come from it,
installs, how long a user may
keep an app on their device,
and APK size getting bigger
over the past 10 years
caused us to really take a step
back and evaluate ourselves.
And we said, what can we do
to make this situation better?
Well, through that
analysis, we came up
with Google Play
dynamic delivery.
Today, you can use
Android app bundle
to benefit from a smaller
app without needing
to refactor your code.
The app bundle also enables
future modularization.
What it does is it
reduces your app
at the moment the
user installs the app.
It allows you to load dynamic
feature modules on demand
at the point when they're
needed further down the road
when the user is
engaging with the app
rather than making
sure there is lots
of pressure at install time.
The Android app bundle, along
with Google Play's dynamic app
delivery, ensure we deliver apps
of the future that are modular,
instant, and dynamic.
We've also tuned the Play
Store's personalization
algorithm to show smaller
apps on lower-level devices.
And as you could imagine,
this increases engagement,
because downloads are more
successful and smaller
apps run better on these
entry-level devices.
This is evident in
all the data we've
collected on user
behavior, and it's
key to think about how
size will affect app store
ranking for these users.
We've done a bunch of feature
improvements for the store.
For example, when a user is
near device disk capacity space,
we suggest users
removing apps that
have either never
been opened or haven't
been used in a long time.
You can see on the
screen here, we
show a mock of apps that
are of a specific size that
haven't been used from
least frequently used
to most frequently used.
And we give the
user who's trying
to install your app an
opportunity to delete
an app that is stale
or they've never used.
And that gives
them an opportunity
to have a better
experience with your app.
Another thing that we
recognized we were not
serving our users
in the best way
was the notion
that a lot of users
manage app installs
when they're on Wi-Fi.
Well, we thought
we could do better.
So we created Play's
Wait For Wi-Fi feature.
It's a known usage pattern
everyone sees all the time,
but we thought Play could
do a better job of serving
this particular user need.
Data management is
important to these users.
So if today, if a user is on
Play via a mobile connection,
when they install,
they can either choose
to install that app immediately
or delay the download
until their device
connects to Wi-Fi
and will initiate the
download in the background
and alert them when the download
and install is complete.
This gives users more control.
It saves metered data.
And most importantly,
it saves money.
We also took a look at
ourselves and realized
that we weren't doing a very
good job from an offline
or a connectivity
tolerance point of view.
So we built a couple
of additional features.
The first one is when the
Play Store is on Wi-Fi,
we cache a larger percentage
of the most visited parts
of the store.
So what that means is if the
user turns mobile data off
or their connectivity is
crummy or their connectivity is
spotty, we can actually serve a
greater percentage of the store
directly from cache.
This is great because
it works offline.
It's also great because
it's a super fast experience
for our users.
Then when they reach the edge
of the cache, they're offline,
and they can't bring up
any additional pages,
we've built another
feature that allows a user
to opt into a notification
that will bring them back
to that part of
the store that they
left once their device
establishes a connection again.
This is a great opportunity
for the user to get back
to Play to download your app.
All the features I
just walked through
are designed to give end users
a high-quality store experience.
But I also want to reiterate
that we have tools available
for you to help you optimize
your app for these Android Go
devices and these markets.
The first, which no one in this
room should be unfamiliar with,
is Android Vitals.
Android Vitals gives you an
insight into ANRs and crashes.
And it's paramount for
understanding the stability
of your app battery.
And the most important part is
that Android Vitals Performance
impacts your promotability
on the Play Store,
especially in the context
of Search and Discovery.
We also introduced a flag,
as Raj previously spoke of,
called Is Low RAM, that allows
you to adjust your app's UX
and distribution choices.
We want you to optimize
for maximum distribution.
Here's an additional
tool to help with that.
We've also included details
about Android Go devices
in the console
pre-launch report.
This allows you to
check on your builds
and understand how they're
performing on actual Android Go
devices on testbeds before
you release to market.
Be sure you incorporate
a regular cadence
with the console
pre-launch report as part
of your normal QA and
release management process.
So you guys have been
to a lot of meetings.
You've heard a lot of things.
And if you've been on your
phone the last 25 minutes,
the four things you
need to remember,
Android Go is a huge
opportunity, keep
your apps small, you should do
everything you can to improve
app quality by leveraging
the Android tools, and Play
is delivering a focused
experience for these users.
Thank you everyone.
If you have any
questions, the four of us
will be up here at the front.
Looking forward to
hearing from you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]